I I commend you on that I think that's
pretty bad thank you and it sounds like
you learned it from your
mom I did I did she was a very grateful
person very grateful um yeah yeah and I
think in losing her I learned it like
tenfold um which has been a gift so she
gave it to me twice she gave it to me
once while she was here and once while
she was gone you know you know I can I
read this little post that you sent on
Instagram it was to your mom
and it said 11 years ago my life changed
in a moment we didn't get to say goodbye
but I think it's because we wouldn't
have known how I see you in my kids
every day I feel you in things I say and
smile because I'm more like you than I
thought I honor You by trying to create
Magic for my family just like you did
for us I love you deeply I'm so grateful
you are a mom this day will always hurt
because you were that special always and
forever mom and it it brought me to
tears it was just like cuz I I remember
remember what a tough time you were
going through it was just an absolute
shock and it's always a shock but for
you it was even more of a shot do you um
do you still uh think about her all the
time do you still get emotional about
her yeah yeah I do I um I do I do think
about her all the time it's it's
interesting in
like
um so I I have I wasn't actually gonna
say this today but I will say it I um I
just wrote a book another one yeah that
will be coming out um next year I
haven't told anybody this is this is
this is me telling people um telling you
um and it um it is it is a love letter
to my mom um about who she was who she
was to me all the things but I also talk
about losing her and how that sort of
affected me in the early days of like
having my children and um you know all
that she's been left with all that she
left me with um and so in writing the
book I had to like really go into some
like sad stuff um and some uncomfortable
places and um and I was just telling my
kids the other day they were like you
seem um lighter about Mimi which is what
they call her and I was like you know
what I I feel that way and it's like
something
about writing my love for her like made
me fall in love with her all over again
but in this like Joyful Way instead of
this deep sad way um and so I will
always I always have this like little
pocket that hurts um but it's lighter
than it used to be um 11 years later and
um and I think it's because I got to
like just really give my love to her in
this book and so I'm really excited for
people to read it it's about the
holidays it's about you know um being
joyful in your life and creating magic
and you know all those things there's
lots of light stuff in it too but it in
the beginning it's really just about her
um and and how she's in everything that
I do now for my kids and my husband and
my family um is to honor her in in like
a really beautiful way so I'm in a I'm
in a really good place with my my
grieving of her because um I feel like
especially in this last year writing the
book we've spent a lot of time together
um and I've really felt her close and
it's been it's been really nice that is
that is awesome